o la gente buena es otro episodio de
versus uno y si alguna vez has querido
estar en un episodio de jubilee
asegúrate de rellenar el enlace del
casting que hay más a wang aquí y me
encanta contar los de en mi instagram
empecemos disfruten no fue estresante yo
me sentía como una mala persona ahora sí
escucho a alguien calificar a una chica
voy a golpearlo y decirle no tomarlo una
hora antes 10 versos 1 calificando 10
chicas
le pedimos a andrew que calificar a 10
chicas en persona
que es más importante la apariencia o la
personalidad la personalidad no
desaparece
yo diría que 60 a 40 quizás 70 30 tal
vez entre esos dos estás preparado para
conocerlas sí claro
i
[Música]
chicas den un paso hacia él
empezando por la mujer más a la
izquierda quiero que las califique es
por su atractivo físico en una escala
del 1 al 10
comienza bien me gusta tu color de
cabello pero me gusta más el aspecto
natural
tiene una buena sonrisa y cabello así
que 89 parecía nervioso en un punto vi
que respiro profunda
tiene ojos bonitos 56
a mí me gustan mucho sus lindes
esto es muy difícil hay buenos ojos y
buena sonrisa hice un contacto visual
muy largo con él
no sé me desmayé un poco
yo solo no es mi tipo personalmente 45
sino que prefiero a alguien un poco más
baja
es linda buena sonrisa 7 voy a decir 6 o
5 me gusta el cabello más largo extra
sobre mi cabeza la gente se siente
intimidada y creo que no es para todos
me sentí como todo ser humano misógino y
terrible así no se siente bien en ronda
1 apariencia and you tiene 3 minutos
para una cita rápida con cada una y
calificar sus personalidades es como
navidad
[Música]
es un extraño regalo al comentario
disculpa ahora chicago no me dices tu
nombre me llamo ángel coloso logro y con
todo encantada andrew creo que es
interesante incluso en retrospectiva
mirar atrás y ver cómo te perciben
cuando no te conocen aún no sabes cómo
te por sí pero será divertido ver el
vídeo siento que podría haber guerra con
el poder que estallaría rápido creo que
un 5 ronda 2 personalidad tengo un par
de amigos que son muy cercanos tal vez
iremos a europa y estoy mal por eso
deberías es increíble
aún tenemos que averiguar la eres
espontánea
cuando fue su última relación bueno
nunca he tenido una relación que hay de
esta bien hace un año que no parecía que
hubiera tanta chispa
cómo describirías el color verde a
alguien ciego no creo que lo haga porque
no creo que en ese momento importe sabes
importa estuvo bien no fue malo fue un 6
estoy temblando mucho estoy estoy apenas
acostumbrándome a intentar no tener una
crisis mental creo que tengo una crisis
mental es que te apasiona y así me
gustaría trabajar en algo con sociedades
humanas o en la conservación de la
naturaleza ya eso es lo que yo quiero
hacer me gustó me sentí cómodo
son las 10 de la noche y estás en una
carretera cuál es tu canción es una
canción cristiana se llama reckless love
eres cristiano sí sí
crecí en la iglesia tuve que apartarme
de todo y rehacerlo a mí me ocurrió lo
mismo
crecí conociendo a dios pero me hizo
falta tener mi propia experiencia
personal para entenderlo mejor y amarlo
más me gusta fue bueno fue un 9 fácil
fue abierta y personal
ya tienes una familia grande este tamaño
medio
soy la del medio y tengo del medio no
había ninguna esa emoción
ay me gusta comprar cosas de segunda
mano eso me encanta y es una buena forma
de pasar el día sin gastar mucho dinero
en especial los ángeles todo me pareció
calmado así que le doy 18 y medio
me gusta cocinar un 7
[Música]
así como la exploradora
si te gusta explorar me gusta viajar
sola en realidad no me también en serio
donde es tu asiento
yo nací en londres voy de visita y creen
que soy muy norteamericana pero aquí
creen que soy la más británica 99 y
medio era directa y tenía buena energía
pero no era abrumadora si no era
atractiva
si solo puedes conocer a una chica ya
sea la que más valoras te por su
apariencia o por su personalidad quién
sería
diría que la chica valorada por
apariencia me gustó su energía sólo con
mirarla escogería la personalidad pero
en ese caso concreto me parece alguien
con quien querría sentarme y hablar y
conocer más y que durará más de cinco
minutos
ganadora
[Música]
bien gracias quiere saber lo que te
calificó en base a la personalidad si te
dio 18
bueno no está mal siento que es difícil
porque es una conversación de sólo 5
minutos si quieren mirarse cara a cara
sí gracias a dios hola hola encantada
encantado de conocerte
y ahora que no lo sé por qué te atrajo
sofía agua su cabello sus ojos su estilo
gracias es muy difícil blanco calificar
a alguien en una escala numérica es algo
insultante mucha gente puede tomarse a
pecho ese número y decir oh me valoran
en lo que sea pero no se puede dar sólo
un número para calificar las grandes
cosas de un ser humano te eligió como se
siente se siente muy bien creo que
aumenta un poco mi ego crees que lo vas
a llamar a solo si él me llama primero
que pensaste cuando los calificó por
apariencia que fue realmente incómodo no
quería hacer contacto visual porque no
quería el contacto visual puede ser
intimidante pero también puede ser muy
vulnerable y bueno fue diferente porque
esta vez sucedía justo enfrente de ti
ocurre siempre pero no lo sabes cómo te
sentiste con la cita note que era una
persona muy genuina de verdad se
preocupó por hacer preguntas y por
conocerme
y lo raro fue que después de todo esto
me enaltece a mí misma cualquiera que
sea el número tú vales más así que me
siento empoderada puedo decir que como
una chica no sé cómo se siente si dicen
que al indicada por mi apariencia muy
valiente y superpoderes mi personalidad
felicidades al elenco si les interesa
aparecer en uno de nuestros vídeos
rellenen el enlace de casting y síganos
en instagram
ahí es donde encontramos a muchos de
ustedes y gracias por ser parte de esto
todos los que participaron son seres
humanos increíbles como siempre
suscriban se síguenos en instagram y nos
ventas si nos vemos la próxima vez
jubilee vive intensamente